spin around and in the chop One Touch pass you
can't score if you don't shoot it look at him
fight through literally fight through to get
to this P they are loving it here on the coy
bench protus in front McMichael score and that
Conor McMichael goal is something what about
the patience the way he pulls the goalie out of
position backand forehand this is a beautiful
goal by this Trio just good work shutting off
the wall by prus getting get around his neet
the Conor McMichael on the board what a piece
come again gallager to fight off the check
here's Aria Aria finds the handle and he gets
it open to his forand goes back against the
grain to the glove side beats for on what a big
goal for mon all Canadians but just really good
secondary work on PX gallager fighting for
that loose Buck on the wall Crees that goal
here's an opportunity for the Oilers and
they score this is off a transitional play
nice job to gain the Zone what a move by
McDavid right there the spin around and
the chop One Touch pass by Newen Hopkins at
Cole to McDavid Newen Hopkins doesn't even
have it on his stick for a second and the
backhand move into the middle beats MOSI by
Hyman now G trying to pull away Nikita
COV up the middle one-on-one with CC
scores what a goal look at fight through
literally fight through to get to this Puck
Cero's concentration on the puck is simply
outstanding he's got the advantage because
he's facing where he wants to go and Skinner
lets that one go five hole what a goal for
kuo LEF faier will grab that to and he scores
from the corner lefer a puts it in off the goal
this is a low percentage shot but you can't
score if you don't shoot it this comes from
below the goal line on off of the helmet of
helot and into the back of the net wow what a
ripper Cent B com to flurry with a shot rebound
they score from the corner it's the captain BS it
home this is a goal scorer's goal execute along
the wall patience stammer gets it to the point
nice job by flurry to get the puck back to the
net and then stammer does what he does knocks
this one right out of the air W down by Jones
up ahead and a pass to the white great pass by
nice do in scar Beauty and it all started with
a pass for M watch this play by Marner he's got
no speed standing still puts the puck between
his legs that opens up the Middle Lane and just
great patience for Maxi kicks the legs up like
he's going to make the shot already Jar's bit
and gone down Jones with the quick up Marner
with a Nifty one between between there's Dad
smiling how do he's look to get it out Liam
O'Brien he's got some room Liam O'Brien is in
O'Brien scores that's a guy that dos all the dirty
work great stick there by Logan [__] look at the
wheels on Liam O'Brian and he knows he's running
on of real estate he keeps this on the back hand
and he goes bar down baby that's as good as it
gets they are loving it here on the C's bench
max Dolby starts out he's in the Middle with
Matthew ni back to what up great move great go
showing just great speed here it's Doby who makes
the play though and stands up I love this move
though an aggressive move to the inside but once
it looked like he was going to cut across he CH to
cut right back but great hands in tight little
forehand backhand up and over the glove here's
tamarus 1,1 points centering it m back tarus with
that open Ice he's got two guys collapsing on him
able to keep it alive but how the patience of
Marner and this one for ver leak he thought it
was going to be going up even between the legs
he's going okay Marner is going to try to get
it top Corner instead he kind of fanned on it
but it was just perfectly executed around the
stick right through the five hole and McKinnon
gallops ahead Nathan McKinnon the drop pass ran
in clear look hangs onto it wraps it the round
and scores it all starts with kale M winning a
puck battle Nathan mckin comes in cuts the middle
and it's the waiting game I thought he might have
tried to stop in short s side but now he's way
better than my thought process berries a wrap
around as the F player couldn't get there in time
hairy moments here for the Islanders yep there you
go and right away this is going to even it up
not even 10 seconds in delay penalty Holstrom
scores wow what a goal from Holstrom Holstrom and
Paso again with more magic Holstrom gets that up
in the toy department didn't seem to have much of
an angle y croak again along the wall ball battles
lefs come up with it broken up inide what a pass
by Kent Johnson he just threw it to the slot and
Patrick Le cleaned it up and then Kent Johnson's
creativity he gets behind the net look out cuz he
knows all eyes are looking at him Patrick l says
how did you see me there cuz it's that quick Well
Done by those three guys especially cylindra on
the dirty areas and when you work that hard and
you get results that's how much fun you have and
the kan's lead n for AO back to AO scor in the
blink of an eye little di go here AO finishes it
puts it to the back of the net but it all starts
with Burns he doesn't B out he stays in he chips
it in there still guys getting it done and this
one is pretty here Shane the flip out in front
of shot score it was Marchman but oh what a pass
from Tyler Sean that line does it again all three
guys a Sapient pass by Tyler San in one motion
little sauce he knows that Mason marchan's coming
with him to the front of the net on the back end
that is about as skilled as you're going to see
tight spaces more make something happen fala to
more who scores the OneTouch unselfish nature
of this goal between his own legs do know has
the puck on his stick he draws attention to his
body in the meantime he Taps the puck between his
own legs picked up by Trevor Moore Kee gains
the line drifts to the right wing gave it to
Byfield Byfield takes it to the net Byfield
back hands it tip score Quinton Byfield with
a stop and start move and then when the Kraken
backed off Byfield took the ice and that's so
important because a couple of Kraken are focused
on Byfield the backhand pass is just superb back
checking is Smith flicks it ahead and now a chance
tomasino on the Breakaway Phil tomasino he's gone
watch this little play there right to the middle
of the ice at thomasino pump fake forehand back
back hand beats lingren to give the Predators the
lead on just an unbelievable sequence of events
there but the lead pass W has a step W in alone
backand score an incredible pass as he finds this
scam to send W in all alone and Nick W lungs
to go to that backand on a breakway where's
the little kick right there the kick to the
backand as he beats Corpus solo tips it over
to kach it's intercepted and here's a chance
back short handed Michael Bley right in scor
it's turned over by Reinhardt right onto the tape
of Han and Michael blein that was a confident move
it's like he knew the entire time that he's going
backand sh that is a huge lift for the Flames here
[Music] early [Music]